that's a hell of a difficult thing to do
right for a huge company to just pivot
i mean it's so interesting to because
we'll talk about your current work
it's like it's clear that pcs were
dominating for several decades
like desktop computers and then mobile
it's unclear it's a leadership question
like like apple under steve jobs when he
came back they pivoted multiple times
you know they build ipads and itunes and
phones and tablets and
great macs like like who knew computers
should be made out of aluminum
nobody knew that that they're great it's
super fun that was steve yeah steve jobs
like they pivoted multiple times
and uh you know the old intel they did
that multiple times
they made drams and processors and
processes and
you